Dulcy director for the FTC the Federal
Trade Commission as we look at debt
collection services around the country
what is the most common complaint you
get from folks about these agencies the
most common complaint is about the
amount of the debt owed or whether the
consumer actually owes the debt that's
that's the biggest category the other
top categories include harassment or
abuse using obscene language and
collecting the debt also threats some
collectors make threats about arresting
the consumer or harming their credit
rating things like that go to the top
categories at what point does the FTC
think harassment actually occurs well
there's not a real bright line between
harassment and just aggressive debt
collecting but certainly obscene
language abusive language repeated phone
calls over a short period of time those
would be considered harassment you
report that complaints of skyrocketed in
recent years something like 14,000 in
the year 2000 to close to 60,000 last
year why such a large increase well
there probably are a number of factors I
think one factor is that consumer debt
is really at record levels and therefore
there are more collectors out there
collecting more debt the they also it's
also true that the number of complaints
that the FTC receives over all about all
sorts of problems have gone up too so
it's part of that general increase but
we're certainly concerned to the extent
that this indicates that problems are
getting worse we're very concerned about
it how many debt collection agencies are
out there right now and what kind of
contact do they have to have with you to
get started there are thousands and
thousands of debt collection agencies I
don't know of any precise number but
they're a huge number of them and
they're collecting billions of dollars a
debt of debt per year they're not
required to register with the FTC or to
contact the FTC we're a law enforcement
agency and we investigate instances of
abuse and bring law enforcement actions
so you know who they are based on the
complaints that you get
through the computer and the phone right
we receive information from a lot of
different sources probably the most
important is consumer complaints if you
want to weigh in ask a question of our
representative from the FTC here are the
numbers to call if you live in the
eastern and central time zones 202 737
triple 0 1 and if you live out west in
the mountain or Pacific time zones 202
737 0 0 0 2 our guest is the assistant
director for financial practices at the
Bureau of consumer protection at the FTC
and found a quote or a comment from a
recent Washington Post piece on all of
this as we talked about the number of
complaints
Joel Winston AAA many Neuberger a Texas
attorney who represents many of these
collection firms estimates that the
average collector makes between 40 and
50 thousand calls a year multiply that
by the 100 thousand collectors that are
out there and that makes about four
billion phone calls a year he says by
comparison these 57,000 complaints filed
are quite small do you see it that way
well Manny's a good friend and I think
he makes a very valid point there's a
point to be made on the other side
however and that is you can't assume
that just because we receive fifty eight
thousand complaints that there were
fifty eight thousand problems there
could have been a lot more problems but
people did not complain to the FTC about
them so in a sense it's it's a it's a
bit of a the tip of the iceberg you said
that these debt collection agencies
don't have to register with you the FTC
but is there a set of rules or general
guidelines laws that govern these
agencies things they absolutely have to
do yes the Fair Debt Collection
Practices Act that's kind of a mouthful
but that that is the federal law that
governs the behavior of debt collectors
and it contains very specific rules
about what collectors must do and what
they cannot do and let's dig deeper into
that Joel Winston let's talk about what
they can do of course they can call you
at home but are there any rules
associated with that yes the collector
cannot call before 8 a.m. and they
cannot call after 9 p.m.
they cannot make repeated calls to
harass consumers they cannot call the
consumer at their place of employment if
they
oh that that's not permitted they can't
call third parties the neighbors the
relatives except to locate where the
debtor actually is that's the only
purpose for which they can make those
calls
what about mail and email contact that's
permissible but again they cannot make
threats that they don't intend to keep
they cannot use abusive or obscene
language the collection needs to be done
in an appropriate way back to that post
piece from recently on all this there
was a Francis Bou Sally of Amherst New
Hampshire featured in this piece told
you the FTC that a debt collector called
him repeatedly about a debt the company
said his daughter owed even though she
had moved out fifteen years before on
November 26 2004 the company called
about six times in 15 minutes and on the
final call the debt collector resided we
sell a Social Security number mentioned
his wife by name and threatened to send
thugs to get him according to this
complaint is this common or unusual this
kind of descriptive complaint yeah I
think it's unusual we certainly have
seen cases where that's happened but
that's certainly not the norm so what
exactly are you looking for and what
process do you go through to put one of
these debt collection companies out of
business we've brought a number of law
enforcement actions in recent months
against debt collectors that were
violating the law and abusing consumers
we've put several of them out of
business we've obtained judgments
against them for millions of dollars to
return to the consumers who were injured
basically we mind the complaint database
we look through those complaints we see
we see patterns of problems with
particular collectors and then we we do
an investigation and if necessary we
prosecute them and if they don't have to
register with you do they and can they
pop up in another form well generally
when we take action against them we
prohibit them from engaging in those
sorts of practices under any form and we
do require that they report in to us
once once we have brought a case against
them they're required to report into the
to us about what they're doing let's go
to calls for Joel Winston of the FTC
Wichita Kansas our first call hi hi
yes yes I was calling about I am had
been put on a Social Security disability
before that time I had been off work for
over two years I was unable and had
still I never be able to work again I
have had to move in with my mother but I
really received over her phone in the
last three years have probably receives
over 40 calls a day I'm had people tell
me that they are handsome towing that
they're glad to have my disease they've
gone as far to say they would collect
their collections when my state was
cleared out I have questioned subpoena
my phone records
it has imagined I probably seeds in
three years well over two thousand calls
and I'm just curious on what and I
should do about that it has got to the
point where it has made my mother a
nervous wreck and has made myself one -
thanks common or uncommon yeah if that
happens more often than we'd like it to
happen but there are lots of honest
collectors out there who don't engage in
that sort of behavior what I'd suggest
to the gentleman is that he contact
either a private attorney or I could
give you a couple of websites where you
can go to to see what your rights are
and and find someone to help you one
website would be a WWN CLC that's NCL
Sea Org that's the site of the National
Consumer Law Center and they provide
assistance to people in your situation
another one is WWN akka an ACA net it's
the National Association of consumer
advocates and again they can put you in
touch with people who can connect can
help you what should people know most
about their rights though folks like
this who call in what should they know
well the first thing I would suggest is
that the consumer go to the FTC website
they have access to to the internet go
to the FTC website where there are some
excellent publications that really lay
out in a simple way exactly what your
rights are but the thing to keep in mind
is if you owe a debt you need to pay it
I mean that's that's that's the law you
can't get out from under your debts just
by refusing to pay but that there are
rules of the road the debt collectors
have to follow if they can't be abusive
they can't call you repeatedly you have
a right to get verification of the debt
if you send a letter to the collector
the collector must provide you with
proof of the depth and you can stop the
collector from from calling you again
that doesn't make the debt go away but
if you send a letter to the collector
saying I don't want to be contacted
anymore
they have to stop San Bernardino
California welcome to the program yes
good morning yes good morning how are
you fine my question is concerning the
new bankruptcy laws and how that will
affect the collection agencies is it
going to increase their ability to go
after you or will they still be under
restrictions that they have now thank
you fairly fresh law of using a
difference since it was enacted no I
really haven't
I don't think that there's really been
time for it to take effect the law the
new bankruptcy law does not change the
rules for debt collectors debt
collectors are still under the same
restrictions and the same obligations
that they were before there is one new
provision though that I think is pretty
important for consumers to know about
and that that is a provision that says
before you declare bankruptcy you have
to go to a credit counselor and try to
get advice about your debt and how you
might pay off your debt which can be a
very useful thing for consumers to to
get that sort of advice the concern is
that there are many organizations out
there that call themselves credit
counselors that are actually trying to
take your money away from you and not
provide you any service so you need to
be very careful about who you go to does
the government provide free service or
low-cost service in that area the
federal government does not but a lot of
local government entities can
I put you in touch with people who are
who are legitimate in addition as part
of this new law there will be a list of
basically government approved credit
counselors that you can go to San
Antonio Texas good morning good morning
how are you
well mr. Winston I have a question for
you basically I had a situation with one
of the internet companies where by not
I'm sorry not an Internet company but uh
so they were phone company and it was on
a trial basis and they give 15 days for
the trial period and I decided not to
take their service and turned it back in
well they advocated that I owed several
bills on that on that situation in which
they were not correct there and they had
sent me a couple of two different months
statement you know to that effect and
then about the third month I got a bill
from I mean I got a statement from a
bill collector my question to you is
this really by law that bill collector
doesn't have the right to even contact
me because I have no contract with them
to provide anything because they even
represented themselves as a
representative of that phone company is
that correct Joel Winston
well the bill collector has a right to
contact you to collect a legitimate debt
but the key is whether the debt is
legitimate in this case if you actually
cancelled the service pursuant to the
terms of the deal yet they're still
trying to collect money you don't owe
the thing you need to do is write a
letter to the collector as well as to
the company and say I cancelled this
here's my documentation hopefully you
did it in writing this proves that in
fact I don't owe this debt and you
should stop collecting it put a face and
a place and a method to all of this
drawwinston how do these debt collection
services operate where are they are they
large entities and and what are they
telling their folks how are they
training them it's a very diverse
industry it's it's huge
hundreds of thousands of collectors some
are very small mom and pop organizations
some are very large and nationwide some
operate out of large large building some
in small buildings so they really run
the gamut but there is sort of a new new
piece of this industry that that's
really grown in the last few years and
that's the debt buyer industry and that
something consumers probably need to
know about a a new group of companies
has arisen to that actually purchases
debt from other debt collectors or from
the original creditors debt that may be
several years old that many people have
tried to collect on and have failed and
these debt buyers will pay literally
pennies on the dollar purchase the debt
and then they make their money if they
can collect on it
sometimes these debt buyers we found
have used overly aggressive tactics and
they've claimed that you need to pay
this debt even though you may not o it
anymore because the statute of
limitations has run so people need to be
careful about that what is the statute
of limitations and is it federal is it
state how does it work it's done on a
state-by-state basis sometimes it's one
year sometimes it's two years sometimes
it's five years
it could even be longer Hyattsville
Maryland for Joel Winston at the FTC
good morning good morning thank you for
c-span welcome thanks for taking my call
sure um my family we moved Oh in the
last two three months and since we've
been at our new location we're getting
collection calls from an agency for the
prior tenant now first of all they
shouldn't even have access to our phone
number so I asked the guy how he got it
and he said through a cell phone
application and I said well what's the
cell phone company he wouldn't give me
that information I think that was a lie
anyway but they've called a couple of
times and I'd like to know what recourse
do we have and can we file a suit
against them i'ma hang up and listen
Thanks yes you kit you could file a suit
you could also complain to the FTC or to
your state attorneys general
the collector is not allowed to contact
third parties in order to collect the
debt for that's owned by somebody else
what you ought to do is write them a
letter send it certified so that you
have a record of it send copies to the
FTC into your state attorney general's
office and demand that the the efforts
stop if they don't then you might want
to consider talking to an attorney speak
more about the the paper the
correspondence aspect of all this so
much of what we talked about involves
phone calls but what rules are out there
for the consumer in terms of their
rights in terms of documentation of
things and conversations and amounts and
that sort of thing that's an important
question because the law is very
specific about what needs to be in
writing and what can be on the telephone
the way it works is that the collector
within five days of first contacting you
must provide you with a letter in
writing that sets out what the debt is
how much you owe who you owe it to and
what your rights are at that point you
have the right to contact the collector
in writing to request that the debt be
verified in other words that the
collector prove that you actually owe
the debt you can also request again it
has to be in writing that the collector
stopped trying to collect from you and
stop contacting you those are your
rights it's important though when you're
when you're making these sorts of
contacts to send the letter certified so
that you have a record of it and you
should enclose any documentation you
have to show either that you don't owe
the debt or that it's a different amount
or whatever the facts are and from the
other end who has the right to call the
credit companies and credit bureaus and
and present them with derogatory
information about you the collector can
report you to the credit bureau if if
it's a legitimate debt and you're not
paying it that's going to go on your
credit record that's something that you
need to know about keep in mind though
if if you're able to convince the the
collector that your debt in fact is not
legitimate that you don't know it you
need to make sure that the collector
corrects that information with the
credit bureau
Jackson Wyoming good morning hello mr.
Winston I am actually a credit
collection agency executive and
ironically our trade association is
having a meeting in Jackson Hole Wyoming
which is where I'm calling from today
and we're talking about quite a few of
these same issues that you're bringing
up at some of the callers this morning
have commented upon I just want to make
a few comments obviously I'm coming from
a different end of the spectrum I think
a comment that I make not only just
yourself but to the callers probably at
large and people wondering I think the
best thing to do for most consumers
would be to communicate with the debt
collector and the worst thing for a
consumer to do is to do nothing that
puts them only in a worse situation in
general I think that unfortunately some
of the things that happen as far as
harassment and abuse and the things that
are defined in the Fair Debt Collection
Practices Act
unfortunately that represents a very
small percentage and the dark underbelly
of what is a very good industry that
provides a good and meaningful service
to businesses merchants and the economy
at large and caller how many employees
you have our company has 84 now we know
what the goal is of course and that's to
have folks make good on their debt but
what do you tell your employees what's
the company is a method what do folks
absolutely have to do how do they have
to behave and where are the lines drawn
well we record all of our phone calls
and we pride ourselves on being somewhat
of the kind learned Jennifer collection
agency we we take the approach that it's
a lot easier to catch more collections
for your clients that you work for if
you are willing to work with the
consumer I think that's a position that
most collection agencies take
I think that certainly the position that
our trade association ACA international
didn't rotate and I think that that is
the that is the position that yields
yield the best results for the consumer
and also the collector and also the
client that the collector is working for
well thanks for sharing your company
situation Joel Winston anything you want
to respond to yeah I think that's a very
legitimate point the the vast majority
of collectors out there are honest
law-abiding and providing an important
service to the economy so we shouldn't
tar the entire industry with the actions
of some bad apples I would also say that
the the organization the gentleman
referred to a CA International is an
excellent organization and they have a
mechanism for considering consumer
complaints and trying to get relief from
the collectors so again listeners might
want to go to a CA International dot org
and if they have have a concern about
what a collector is doing and the
collector is a member of that
association the the a CA can can often
fix the problem do all companies hire
out their debt collection or do some
larger companies do their own work and
are there rules different than the third
party for people yes there are both
in-house collectors and third party
collectors in-house meaning the the
person you owe the debt to in the first
place tries to collect it those in-house
collectors are not subject to this
particular federal law the Fair Debt
Collection Practices Act so there aren't
the same level of specific rules however
they are subject to the more general
consumer protection laws in particular
the Federal Trade Commission Act which
prohibits unfair or deceptive practices
so it's not the case that these
collectors are free to do whatever they
want they still can be prosecuted by the
FTC Columbus Ohio for Joel Winston at
the FTC hi there hi I was calling
because I've been in credit collection
for 36 years
and I was wondering I know for a fact
that a lot of the collectors work
strictly on Commission with their
companies and that a lot of their
tactics are driven by the fact that they
want to collect as much money as they
can so I know personally that things
have been ignored when they no rules are
being broken and I was wondering if you
know that you work in a company that's
allowing this to happen if the trade
commission has a hotline number or
something this sort of thing can be
reported because I know I know that's
what happens for a fact and that happens
more often than not and it's all
basically for the bottom line a little
different than what the executive said
right I guess that's the other side of
myself all right it's true that many
collectors work on Commission and it's
true that creates some incentive for
them to to bend the law if if if there
are collectors out there who are
interested in informing the FTC about
their concerns they can contact us
either online at ftc.gov or by the phone
at 877 FTC help heop as the level of
personal that continues to rise these
companies grow in their number do you
see more regulation by the folks here in
Washington coming down the line in this
area there have been a lot of efforts to
tweak the Fair Debt Collection Practices
Act to improve it in certain ways and in
fact my agency the Federal Trade
Commission has recommended to Congress
several specific reforms that we think
would be helpful but in general I think
if you talk to anyone in the industry
and the consumer advocates anyone who's
who's involved in this issue they would
tell you that this particular law is one
of the best federal consumer protection
laws out there Mill Hall Pennsylvania
our last call hi hi okay good I'll try
to be quick okay I had an experience
with this and I can fill you in on some
details at this gentleman's afraid to
say now I used to work for a credit card
company and I was going for a law degree
so I know I'm talking about then I was a
victim of this because I'm house done
with
incurable illness there are legitimate
collection agencies if you say default
on a credit card which I ended up doing
baking come after you with the
collection agency they have rights to do
that but what happens is they'll
eventually give up but and they collect
on it two ways they collect insurance
and write it off as a loss on their
income tax after they do that they can
no longer come out after you but they
can put it on a credit report and this
last in my case for seven years if you
have no more bad debt in that seven year
period that's forgiven and yeah the
credit card company won't even send you
a credit card again see hi how are you
doing we forgive you here another credit
card now what's happening started in
1995 after the Republicans took over
Congress in the Senate these companies
that call themselves debt collectors but
they're illegal they're run by criminals
and con artists they buy files which
should be illegal under a Privacy Act
summers our personal information is
getting out their credit card companies
banks etc they're selling their old
files to the pseudo companies which I
think are illegal to begin with now
after the seven year period in my case I
started getting phone calls and I'm ill
with a disease they were there first
upsetting but then I thought through the
law and realized they don't have a case
against me and they can they don't have
any legal right to the money they're
claiming they trying to get from you and
they they take mafia tactics they
threaten you
I had to unplug my phone I'd hang up a
ring and hang up a did ring they're
criminals they have no right to the
information they have but they have no
right to even try to collect them what
on these debts which aren't theirs and
they're not collecting it for the can
let's get a response from our guest
final thought okay this is an issue
that's gotten a lot of debate in recent
months about the ability of a collector
to collect on a debt that's that several
years old and perhaps has passed the
point at which they can legally collect
it what what the law says is that
collect if the debt has not been
discharged in bankruptcy or otherwise
been legally eliminated they can try to
collect that debt but they cannot make
any claim to you that they can they can
legally enforce that right in other
words if you still owe the debt if you
haven't paid the debt and hasn't been
discharged
then you are still responsible to pay it
but they cannot go to court and make you
pay it and they cannot claim that that
they can do that FTC gov is the website
to learn more information about consumer
rights and how this whole process works
we